university of southern california
president is facing calls to resign in
the wake of sexual misconduct
allegations against a former doctor at
the school 200 faculty members signed a
letter yesterday saying president max
Nikias lost the moral authority to lead
us see that comes as several women filed
lawsuits accusing us see if not properly
responding to complaints against against
campus gynecologist
George Tyndall bianna golodryga is here
with troubling allegations be on good
morning good morning these allegations
go back dozens of years
USC says over the last few days and has
received around 200 reports about dr.
Tyndall some of his alleged victims are
now represented by the same lawyers who
represented the victims of disgraced MSU
dr. Larry Nasser and like in that case
there are now questions about who knew
what and when USC has let me down
USC master student Daniela moja Saab
says during an STD test in 2016
gynecologist George Tyndall sexually
harassed and molested her he made me
feel extremely uncomfortable and
violated mahasabha and six other women
are suing the doctor and USC for
allegedly failing to properly respond to
numerous complaints made about him
Tyndall worked for the university
student health center for about 30 years
accusations against him include taking
inappropriate pictures of hundreds of
patients genitals making sexual comments
about patients bodies and repeatedly
assaulting patients under the guise of
medical treatment reportedly USC was
aware of dr. Tyndall's inappropriate
conduct before I was even born the
university admits Tyndall was the
subject of eight complaints since 2000
but according to one of the lawsuits he
wasn't put on leave until 2016 when a
concerned nurse reported him to the
campus rape crisis center after an
investigation he was fired last June
it's really unclear why USC and its
clinic leadership didn't take action
sooner reporter Matt Hamilton helped
break the story for the Los Angeles
Times the faculty at USC they're in a
state of revolt right now
in a letter addressed to the Board of
Trustees Tuesday 200 faculty members
called on us see president max Nikias to
step down expressing outrage and
disappointment over his alleged failure
to protect against repeated and
pervasive sexual harassment and
misconduct
Nakia said in a statement he understands
the Faculty's anger and frustration and
is committed to rebuilding their trust
the USC board of trustees said in a
statement that it is disturbed by the
allegations against Hindle but has full
confidence in president nakiya's
leadership we reached out to dr. Tyndall
but have not heard back he denied any
wrongdoing
to the Los Angeles Times he was that
campuses only gynecologist for so many
years and the loss for such a large
school in the Los Angeles Times this
reporter reached out to dozens of other
gynecologists and asks if some of these
tactics were acceptable they said no
they should have raised a lot of red
flags something tells me there may be
more to come on that story thank you
very much bianna